welcome dear cbs this morning needles
moment oil globe guidance especially
morning with my team bring tony award
nomination
again and gio from the new public
library for the performing arts at
lincoln's a gel king is their way to a
great big stars
coming d okay wie er hier john  en or
comment here from lincoln center
original showtime
couple minutes for closer jon alright
shine johnny wireless baby north to time
tonino mini brandon dictate dickson
is okay year in chimay blue
hi bokkers oil line others you may
know fly like this one abs chicken
so bring with lashing  debica you know
what this is like you know the morning
je make up its own the nomination
what you think most people free kids and
the go find you go we slept he this is
just like a letter thing
oceanic let's see yes something like that picture i
give  you up port and here sorry
sitting by the palms watching me ten
that so can harbor a word net
german points all those leds longer codes
name is a  number that with you
yes youtube and ow yes i the real is a
level a drop patient meter party
so when i need to wrap your script 4 nice
dmx and to the needs i no
degree drm nervous a preview media
leading a team high stakes ran and  you
here something quiet here than an osama hotel
you
when the yuther you know what you
take
thank you sir van de ama de tineke's
johny voners olino jeff rense tony
nomination i come for play such as
be for this jeep and telephony
nomination coming for  play the mighty
shirt news the business ai i know it
gets more attention
no this is squirting i want me in
a cell had you spread
keep my mind on the show and and push
push and dino
those meteor things you guys that
went  the study sparkling grape is for
that shock absorber